le haut karabagh au coeur des
discussions ce matin trop le ministre
russe des affaires étrangères et son
homologue arménien en qu'une nouvelle
réunion organisée par moscou après la
signature d'un accord de paix entrée en
vigueur le 10 novembre dans cette région
contestée du haut karabagh a les deux
hommes ont tenu une conférence de presse
dans la foulée de cette rencontre on
retrouve notre correspondant antoine
claireaux encore un bon jour compte
rendu avec vous antoine de ces échanges
oui le ministre arménien des affaires
étrangères fraîchement nommé s'est rendu
à moscou pour son premier déplacement à
l'étranger l'occasion de souligner que
les accords du 9 novembre conclu entre
la russie l'azerbaïdjan et l'arménie ne
sont qu'une première étape et qu'il est
maintenant nécessaire de définir un réel
statut à cette région du haut karabagh
et valait d'ailleurs disposé à en
discuter directement avec bakou dès que
la situation sur le terrain sera
réellement stabilisée et le rôle de la
turquie clarifier écoutée elle la
turquie en tant que principal
instigateur et inspirateur de
l'agression de l'azerbaïdjan contre le
peuple du haut karabagh continue à
mettre en place une politique
pernicieuse pour la région cela oblige
la communauté internationale employer
tous les moyens possibles afin de
contraindre la turquie à s'abstenir de
toute action pouvant aggraver davantage
les tensions et les personnes
la turquie doit retirer ses forces
armées et les groupes terroristes
affiliés de la zone du conflit du haut
karabagh et du sud caucase en général
pour le moment il n'y a pas eu de
message clair sur le retrait des
terroristes étrangers de la région
sergueï lavrov s'est à son tour félicité
du respect du cessez-le-feu conclu il ya
maintenant quasiment un mois mais aussi
du travail des soldats russes de la paix
sur le terrain le ministre russe d'après
lui l'objectif doit maintenant être le
retour à une vie normale pour toute la
population sur place sans considérations
ethniques ou religieux sergueï lavrov a
également commenté une déclaration du
responsable européen du responsable
européen
de la diplomatie josep borrell qui s'est
inquiété du rôle de la russie mais aussi
de la turquie dans ce dossier du haut
karabagh écoutez si je comprends bien
monsieur morel et d'une certaine manière
préoccupé par le fait que quelqu'un
d'autre part à l'union européenne puisse
prendre l'initiative dans le monde
d'aujourd'hui
je vous rappelle que si par exemple
concernant les balkans
le prédécesseur de monsieur morel madame
mot guérini a déclaré il ya un certain
temps quand l'union européenne se
présentent dans les balkans ou dans
d'autres régions
les autres n'ont rien à y faire ensuite
quand perplexe nous avons posé des
questions ils ont commencé à faire
semblant d'avoir été mal interprétés
mais en réalité tout le monde avait
parfaitement compris le dossier du haut
karabagh est donc encore loin d'être
clos mais au moins maintenant c'est la
diplomatie qui a pris la relève
prochaine étape désormais l'arménie ou
le ministre russe des affaires
étrangères vient d'accepter une
invitation de la part de son homologue
arménien merci beaucoup antoine
claireaux depuis moscou